the Russia collusion hoax collapsed
under the weight of its own absurdity
earlier this year as you know and yet
amazingly it is still claiming victims
to this day Roger stone went on trial in
Washington this week officially stone is
being charged with lying to Congress
that's bitterly amusing if you think
about it given that Congress cannot be
charged with lying to you which it does
constantly but in Washington everyone
understands that's just a pretext Roger
stones real crime was giving Donald
Trump political advice for 30 years for
that he faces life behind bars
one person who clearly understands
what's actually happening and strongly
approves of it is the presiding judge in
the case Amy Berman Jackson Jackson is
an Obama appointee and she's
transparently and aggressively political
months ago Jackson prohibited Roger
stone from publicly defending himself in
the case CNN and MSNBC were free to
continue to slander stone and of course
they relentlessly did that but if stone
said a single word in his own defense
Jackson vowed to put him behind bars now
how could Jackson do that in a country
with the First Amendment well she
couldn't it's blatantly unconstitutional
but Donald Trump is hated here in
Washington so nobody's stopped her
Jackson just did it anyway just like in
the third world
Jackson's behavior in court has turned
out to be even more ludicrous and
unprofessional assuming that's possible
at times she has literally rolled her
eyes and snorted at stone suggesting
he's guilty before the trial even
started her judgments had been
transparently political yesterday for
example during jury selection one of the
prospective jurors turned out to be a
former press secretary in the Obama
administration who admitted that she
despises Donald Trump and has friends in
the federal prosecutor's office which is
trying the case her husband meanwhile
works at the Justice Department which is
prosecuting Roger stone the woman claims
she had followed the Muller
investigation closely but somehow had
never quote read or heard anything about
Roger stones case and didn't have a
strong opinion about him uh-huh no sober
person could take that claim seriously
but Amy Berman Jackson did she acted
like it was all complete
fine and on the level when roger stones
lawyers ask that woman be removed from
the jury pool Jackson refused personal
conflicts she said were quote not
automatically disqualifying what ought
to be automatically disqualifying is Amy
Berman Jackson's behavior from the bench
no fair person could condone it if they
were still honest liberals left in this
country they would be protesting outside
the courtroom